All of the television programs and all
the things we'd done were all very important.
But what with the urgency of
the landing on the moon
everything was checked and
checked and checked again
because if we'd messed up I mean there would have been a lot of people very, very disappointed.
And when you look back now and realize there was 220 million people in Europe watching it.
Goonhilly had done a lot of the broadcasts from America showing the launches of various
vehicles that went into space from
Mercury, Gemini, right up to the Apollo series.
With the Apollo series they
showed all the launches because
everybody was very interested.
'Liftoff on Apollo 11.'
When they launched on the Tuesday
away they went
and you think well this is going to
happen now
and because we'd seen so many of the
launches so many we almost felt involved
with the project.
And when finally they
got to the moon, they went into the lunar
orbit and they broke free and went down
I mean the atmosphere in the old
operation control area was electric,
it was electric.
Nobody spoke.
There was no need to speak.
Because if somebody had
spoken I think they were broken the spell.
Finally, when they opened the hatch
and they came down
we were almost walking down there a step
at the time with him because we've been
involved, we felt part of it.
And when they finally took off and they
joined with the command module and
literally it was all over.
It was a wonderful, wonderful experience.
I can't really explain exactly what it was like.
When I left in the morning I walked out
the door and if someone had said to me
'You'll be back here in 50 years time to
talk about it' I wouldn't have believed it.
It was two very important things that
went on, the landing on the moon
and Goonhilly handling the broadcast.
My responsibility on the night of the
broadcast I was in charge of the
television switching, patching from the
communication equipment through the various feeds and then the outlet which
would go via the microwave link up to
BBC for Europe or for the UK.
Now, a lot of people thought that the pictures from the moon came directly to Goonhilly,
but they didn't.
They came eventually,
because of a satellite failure over the
Atlantic ocean,
it came in by a very long route.
It came from the moon to Australia, Australia to
America, America across to Japan,
and Japan to Goonhilly.
When I came here in the early 60's
there was only number one.
Number two came in,
they built in the late 60's, it
was just a modern version of number one
Number 1, well they call it Arthur now,
it was built to a design which was
typically British.
It was built like a battleship.
Aerial 1 weighs 1100 tons.
I mean it is there forever.
It had a character and even though it
was built like a battleship it is the
Grand Old Lady of Goonhilly,
and I just hope it'll always be here.
Goonhilly was built on this site
because it used to be
a radar station during the war,
but important
thing at the time when the satellite
system started coming in they wanted to
be as far west as possible and as far
south as possible and the best site
they found was on Goonhilly Downs.
I came to Cornwall
in the early 1960s to work at Goonhilly.
When I got here I looked around and thought
'have I made the right choice?'
It was a bleak, dismal, windy place.
I just didn't think that I made the right decision but
I'm afraid 60 odd years later I did
make the right decision.
I'd been part of it
as far as I was concerned.
I was there, I'd done it, and I think I
achieved a great deal.
And it's a legacy that will go on.
My great-grandchildren say
'hey, my granddad was involved with that.'
To me that is a legacy and
it was a great part of my working life at Goonhilly.